SUNNI YUEN: OK, welcome
to today's talk at Google.
I'm Sunni Yuen.
I'm a member of
Google's legal team
and also a member
of the Talks team.
And this is Manushu Shah, who
is a software engineer and also
a member.
And today, we're here
to welcome Nikhil Goyal.
Nikhil Goyal is a 20-year-old
education activist
who has been lauded by
the "Washington Post"
as the future
education secretary.
No pressure there.
And also named by "Forbes"
as one of the top 30
under 30 list.
Nikhil is known for his
passionate viewpoints
on the existing American
education system, K to 12,
and his bold ideas for
how to revolutionize it.
So welcome, Nikhil.
NIKHIL GOYAL: Thanks
for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'd love to talk for
just a couple minutes,
and then we can jump into a
more extended Q&A and more
conversation-based format.
So to give a little
background of my story,
I graduated from Syosset
High School on Long Island
in January 2013.
It's a fairly
high-ranking high school.
A lot of kids go onto
Ivy League institutions.
It's one of the highest-ranking
on the "Newsweek"
rankings at least.
And at school, I
became very frustrated
with the way schooling was done.
And I noticed a
couple of things.
One, that students
at my school, they
were incredibly stressed out.
They were depressed, anxious.
They were hooked on
prescription drugs.
They were, overall, really
unhealthy human beings.
And they were sacrificing a lot
of their sleep, mental health,
well-being and happiness in
order for this one pursuit
of getting into college.
So everything in
terms of their grades,
their extracurricular
activities,
was dedicated to padding
their college application.
And I felt that this was a
very artificial and not so
worthwhile task.
That you're losing a lot
of the joy and creativity
in learning when you
are single-handedly
pursuing this goal that may
not lead to necessarily success
later on in life.
And I was looking
at these problems.
I was talking to teachers.
I was speaking with
students about, what
do they think about their
schooling experiences,
their problems with the
system, their critiques of it?
And that just led
me to do research
on the American
education system.
I was somebody who,
throughout my time in school,
was somebody who did not
really enjoy school very much.
I found it to be very
boring, alienating.
And oftentimes, did
not really satisfy
what I was most
interested in, which
was politics, and
current affairs,
and international relations.
These topics were
not discussed at all
in the regular school day.
But what was quite
interesting and what
I learned in high
school was that I
found the most worthwhile
experiences to be after school.
So in my friend's
[INAUDIBLE] debate
team, or my
cross-country team where
I was a runner all year long.
Or going on the UN model team.
Those kinds of
experiences where I
was allowed to engage in
experiential, hands-on,
project-based
learning experiences.
Where I was allowed to work
with people of different ages.
Where I was allowed to use the
real world as my classroom as
opposed to sitting
in a school building,
those experiences really
gave me a better insight
on how the world works.
How social change happens.
And just how you can
acquire the skills
necessary for adult life.
And those experiences,
I was just wondering,
why can't this be the
school day itself?
I'm making so many friends.
I'm enjoying myself.
Why is it that I'm finding
myself to be so bored
in my regular classes?
Couldn't there be
a better option?
And just that basic
curiosity of like,
could the system be better?
Like, is there a better
system out there?
And how can we bring it to
more places, really drove
my thinking and my research.
So I graduated from high
school in January 2013.
And after that, basically what
I did was go around the country.
I went to cities like Chicago,
Philadelphia, New York, Boston,
San Francisco.
And I visited something called
democratic progressive and free
schools.
And these are schools
that are basically
schools that focus on
self-directed learning.
They believe that
the school should not
be divorced from the community.
They should be deeply
ingrained with one another.
That adults and students should
have reciprocal relationships.
That there should be some
kind of democratic process.
So in some of these
schools, the students vote
on school policies in something
called a democratic meeting.
And just a really radical
idea of how education is done.
And it hearkens
back to the idea of
progressive democratic
education, which
has been in this country
for a very long time.
Some of you may be familiar
with a man named John
Dewey, or Maria Montessori.
And these were the two pioneers
of progressive education
in the 20th century.
John Dewey with the U
Chicago lab school, and then
Montessori in
Italy, and a number
of schools around the
world-- thousands of them.
And that was a very big
period in the 20th century.
And in the 1960s, you had this
movement called the free school
movement, which
basically coincided
with the anti-war
movement against Vietnam
War, the civil rights movement,
the feminist movement, student
power movements.
Just a really big time
for transformation,
revolution, and protest.
And so one of the overlooked
movements, one of the things
that's often not mentioned
in the history books,
is the free school movement.
And the free school
movement was a movement
that was dedicated to completely
transforming the education
system from the ground up.
And the person who kind
of led this movement,
and who kind of inspired
it from the beginning,
was a man named A.S. Neill.
And A.S. Neill basically
was a British educator
who was a teacher for
a long period of time
and was very frustrated
with how education was done.
He dropped out of the teaching
profession many times.
And he was very
alienated by the way
kids were learning in school
and how they were treated.
At the time, corporal punishment
was very, very widespread
in British schools.
And so A.S. Neill
in 1921, he started
a school called Summerhill.
And Summerhill was a school.
It was first founded in Germany,
and then they moved to England
a couple years later.
And it remains there today.
It's going to be celebrating
their 100th anniversary
in a couple years.
And this is a school, it was
a very, very radical school
at the time.
Like I mentioned,
this school was--
they featured
non-compulsory classes.
So students did not have to
necessarily go to class at all
during their entire
time at school.
There was equal relationships
between students and teachers.
There was democratic process.
So maybe twice a
week, the students
come together as a
school community and vote
on school policies.
And then, there's all
this ample time for play.
I mean, I think one of the
great things about this school
and many of these
free schools is
that they let children really
truly live out their childhood.
And get to explore and
find their passions
at a very young age as opposed
to chaining them to a desk
and telling them, you have
to learn this at this time.
You have to read it by this age.
And you have to be able to
accomplish basic skills.
And the evidence suggests-- I've
been to many of these schools
and it's not just anecdotal.
But the evidence suggests,
based on a lot of research
by people like
Peter [INAUDIBLE],
is that the kids
in these schools,
even though they necessarily
weren't forced to take classes,
they overwhelmingly
learned the formal--
they learned the formal skills.
So reading, basic
literacy, writing,
math, numeracy, and so much more
even if they're not forced to.
Because what
happens is that when
you create an environment where
there is a lot of opportunities
for learning, for play,
for peer-to-peer learning
because there's no age
segregation in these schools.
The older kids and
the younger kids
intermix and mingle
with each other.
When you have those kinds
of factors and principles
in place, you create a system
where the kids not only learn
more efficiently,
but they retain
the curiosity, the creativity,
the intrinsic motivation,
that I think all
children are born with.
And it's formal
schooling that oftentimes
leads to the depreciation of
that engagement and curiosity.
And so what I found-- what
I wanted to do in the book
was do two things.
1, expose and show the problems
with American education
and just conventional
schooling in general.
And then offer this blueprint
of where education is actually
succeeding.
Where is it being
very effective?
And in the former, I show
a lot of evidence and data
that suggests that-- for
example, student engagement.
The levels of
student engagement,
if you look at the chart.
Gallup did this study
a couple years ago.
They call it a
school cliff, where
if you look at students'
engagement from kindergarten
to 12th grade, it
is a downward spiral
as you go through more
years of schooling.
Curiosity is the same way.
Creativity.
Asking questions.
The number of questions
kids ask decrease as they
go through formal schooling.
Obviously, it's not
necessarily for everyone.
Not everyone has
this happen to them.
But across the board, this
is a systematic problem.
So I was looking at the problems
of the American schooling
system.
I was looking at the history.
Where was the system created?
What was the purposes of it?
And then I wanted to show that
there is another education
system that's possible.
And there is Montessori schools.
There are Waldorf schools.
They call them just progressive
schools, the free school
movement.
I mean, there's thousands
of these schools
around the country.
But the big problem is
that a lot of these schools
are private schools.
So they are largely
unaccessible to the population
that arguably needs
it the most, which
is poor children of color.
Which are generally, as you may
have seen, are in the schools
where it's very regimented.
There are basically
doing test prep
for six to seven hours a day.
They have to walk in the
hallways with their hands
behind their backs because they
fear that if the student is not
able to cooperate and act in
a disciplined and obedient
fashion, they're not going
be able to do well in life.
The "New York Times" just
showed this video of a teacher
at Success Academy,
a school that's
predominately for poor
black and brown children,
harassing a child.
And I think this is
a systematic problem
at many of these schools that
deal with children of color.
So my mission and my
objective with this book
and with my writing
and my reporting
is to show that progressive
education should
be able to reach the
most vulnerable people
in our society.
And one of the
examples I show is
there's a group of schools
actually in New York
state called the New York
State Performance Consortium--
Standards Consortium.
And this is a group of
public progressive schools
that basically have been given
a waiver by New York state
where they only have to
take one Regents exam, which
is the English one.
And instead of the
other Regents exams,
they get to submit a portfolio
of, say, a science paper
or science project, a
history paper, a math proof.
Really, performance-based
tasks that
show what a student
can accomplish.
And I arguably think
this is much better
than what any standardized
test can show a student.
And what they find is that
these schools generally
work with a population that has
been disengaged, that is poor,
that is special education
and minority students.
And even when you
consider those stats,
the students do better in
terms of graduation rates.
They have lower dropout rates,
higher student engagement
rates.
And arguably, they
do better in college
than students in
comparative public schools.
I mean, that's one of the things
I'm looking at in the future.
I'm hoping to study that and
study progressive education,
at least in
communities of color.
And how we can bring
about these changes,
not only in the private system,
but in the public system where
I think most kids are.
And where I think we need to
see a major transformation.
And I'll just end on this.
One of my ideal
visions for education
is treating the city
and the community
as the classroom itself.
So in the '60s, during
that period of time,
there was a group of schools
called School Without Walls.
And a School Without Walls--
there was one in Philly,
for example, basically
believed that the community
should be the classroom.
So the kids spent
most of their time
in museums, in libraries, in art
galleries, in athletic centers,
in bakeries, and in all parts
of the community and the city.
And that's where they learned.
They, obviously, did
have some formal classes,
but they learned based on
side-by-side mentorship
and apprenticeship and
experiential learning.
And it was just
really incredible
because kids who were
formerly disengaged,
kids who were ready
to drop out of school,
came to these places like
the School Without Walls,
and they became
completely re-energized
by the idea of learning.
So I'd love to see this idea
of a city as a classroom.
And I think the writers,
like I mentioned in the '60s,
you have Jonathan Kozol, Herbert
Kohl, John Holt, Paul Goodman.
These ideas were hashed out
and debated very thoroughly
in the '60s.
Between 1968 and
1972, these ideas
were on the front pages
of the "New York Times."
So these are not
necessarily new ideas.
I think I update them for
the 21st century society
that we live in.
So I'm looking forward to seeing
how these changes come about.
And I think there's another
education system that
is possible if we have
the political will
and we have the movement
coming from parents, educators,
students, and policy
makers for a more
progressive and democratic
education system.
SUNNI YUEN: So you may be
one of the few people who,
after graduating from high
school, went back to school.
NIKHIL GOYAL: Right.
SUNNI YUEN: Many schools.
SUNNI YUEN: A whole year of
traveling, going to schools.
You couldn't get enough of it.
NIKHIL GOYAL:
Well, what I wanted
to do was not go to the
schools that were like mine,
because I found that
to be very depressing.
I mean, if you go to like
any American high school,
the kids are-- either they're
high or they're-- I mean,
they're on some kind of drug,
or they're sleep deprived.
They're hunched over.
I mean, it's like
zombies, essentially,
in many of these
high-achieving high schools.
And I didn't want
to see that again.
And I wanted to see,
where are the kids happy?
It's really funny because
I quote this principal
at the Workshop School
in Philadelphia.
It's a progressive school.
And one day, there
was the superintendent
of schools in Philly was
touring a school, which
is an amazing, amazing school
for poor kids in West Philly.
And the first thing the
superintendent said,
oh, the kids are happy.
And then, Simon Hauger, who's
the principal, goes and says,
oh, actually, this guy
goes to schools every day
and he notices that
kids aren't happy
and they're bored
to death every day.
And here, he comes
to this school
and the kids are engaged and
very interested in learning.
It's a very stark
contrast to what you see
in most American high schools.
So yeah, I wanted to see
the other side of this,
and see where the kids are
actually achieving very well.
And I think I found some really
good answers and solutions
that I hope more
people learn about.
SUNNI YUEN: And did you
set off on this school road
trip-- which sounds kind
of like an oxymoron.
Did you set on this
road trip knowing
that you wanted to write a
book based on what you found?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
I mean, I wanted to write
about it in some form.
As I went to these schools,
I noticed that-- I mean,
one of my main
purposes was to bring
the ideas of the '60s back.
I wanted to show that
these ideas, that
what they talked about--
what Kozol and Holt
and [INAUDIBLE] talked
about in the '60s
are very, very
relevant to today.
I quote a lot of these people.
And people are
saying, oh, why are
you quoting people from
1965, like how are they
even relevant?
But if you read those books,
it's quite interesting.
Because almost word for word,
they're still applicable
to the education system today,
primarily because the system
has largely remained the same
in many forms and structures.
So yeah, I wanted to do that.
And I wanted to show
the public that there
was another way possible.
SUNNI YUEN: And are you
familiar with AltSchool,
which was formed by-- founded,
I should say, by a former Google
engineer?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
I have not visited one.
I've heard some good
things about it.
I've heard some not so
good things about it.
I would like to
visit one and see
what it's like for a person.
I usually don't try to judge
a school before I visit it.
SUNNI YUEN: That's very wise.
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
SUNNI YUEN: So I mean,
the AltSchool model
is supposed to be concentrated
on project-based learning,
which is something
that you advocate
very strongly for in your book.
And there's sort of this
other element, which
is premised on the idea
of building personalized
curricula for students.
And again, using
data to create-- it's
very contemporary
for millennials,
creating playlists.
So students can just
look at their homework.
Instead of calling it homework,
they look at their playlists.
And they naturally can build
a project based on that.
And the idea is
that that can scale.
That model can scale based
on the data that they have.
They can model what's optimal
for a given student based
on their personality and stage.
What are your thoughts on that?
NIKHIL GOYAL: So I'm all
in favor of tailoring
an education to the individual.
I mean, there's been
a lot of worries
about personalized learning.
Personalized learning sounds
like a really good idea,
but the implementation
has been very shaky,
I find in the past couple years.
Primarily because
what happens is
that if personalized
learning just
says, if you're going to
learn this set curriculum,
and you're just going to learn
it however you choose to,
I don't think that's a very big
leap in the right direction.
I'm all in favor
of kids learning
what they would like to
and crafting a curriculum
based on those interests.
But if the end goal is
the same curriculum,
then I don't think that's a
very big iteration of the kind
of current system we have.
But yeah, I would
love to see this.
I mean, it's obviously still
playing out in many schools
around the country.
And I'd love to
see how it's going.
But yeah, that's my big worry.
Because if we're just
trying to meet this one goal
and you get to
decide however you
want to-- how to
get to that goal,
I'd take some issue with that.
A lot of these
progressive schools,
they do have
curriculums available,
but they do let the
kids really work
with the teacher and the
kind of school community
at large to decide how best--
what's the best topic or what's
the best way to approach
a certain issue that I
want to learn.
So project-based
learning is a great idea.
I think it's practiced
for many, many years.
But I think one of the things
that we need to consider--
and I think one of
the fatal flaws,
one of the flaws of the
progressive education community
is oftentimes not realizing
that kids may prefer a more
direct instruction approach.
And I think we should have
all options available to kids,
even though project-based
learning tends to be, I find,
more effective and more
engaging for kids who have
been turned off by a school.
But I think we should have as
many options available for kids
in school.
MANUSHI SHAH: So just
continuing on that,
you have seen the progressive
and democratic school success
with, like the range is usually
in hundreds of students,
considering from
kindergarten to high school.
When you think about
the current education
system and the current
school districts,
they are in range of
thousands of students.
If you try to continue this
same model of letting everyone
vote on decisions,
there will still
be a cohort who is not happy
with the overall decision
because it's such a huge cohort.
So how would you handle that?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
So for the first part,
like the big banks,
I would like to
break up the schools,
in terms of making them smaller,
much smaller institutions.
I mean, there's
a lot of evidence
to show that schools with
under 250 students, or about
300 students, they have
smaller class sizes.
They have strong relationships
between students and teachers.
And if you go to most
American high schools,
they are gargantuan
institutions.
I mean, thousands upon
thousands of kids in the school.
And what happens with that
is that the kids are lost.
And they don't have
true relationships
with teachers and other
students because they're just
being shuffled from
classroom to classroom.
And there's not enough time
for that strong relationship
building.
So I'd love to make schools
much smaller places.
And a lot of these
progressive schools
are-- I think one of
the successes of them
is because they are
very small institutions.
And that has a lot
to do with funding
and the way school districts
are structured, and taxes.
There's a lot of big
obstacles to that.
But I would really like
to see smaller schools.
So for the second point
for the democratic meeting.
Well, what's great about these
schools is that, obviously,
yeah, there's always
going to be some cohort
of kids that don't
like the decision,
or some adult who doesn't
like the decision.
So to give an example,
just to show like what
these kids actually do.
At the Philly Free
School one of the kids
were interested in walking
barefoot at the school.
It's a very small school.
And so one kid, I think
like a seven-year-old,
wanted to propose it.
And he brought it to
the school meeting
and people talked about it.
I think they eventually
voted it down.
But they had this really good
discussion about this issue.
There were 7-year-olds debating
15-year-olds and adults
debating each other.
And eventually, they
came to a consensus
that this wasn't the best idea.
And at this school also,
they have something called--
it's kind of like a tribunal.
They have a set of rules.
So if a student breaks
a rule, they actually
go to court in the school.
There's a jury.
I think there's two students
and one adult on this jury.
So for example, I
believe one kid,
he or she accidentally
broke the ceiling fan.
And the student didn't tell
a staff member or anybody
at the school.
And it was a hazard.
And so they brought the
student up to the meeting.
They allowed the student
to bring in witnesses
or to vouch for their opinion
and say, why did you do this?
Like, what's the penalty?
And they had this really
good discussion about why.
Letting the kid know
that this was not right,
that this was kind of
restorative justice.
That you need to figure out a
way to mend the community back.
It was a really
amazing interaction
between this seven-year-old,
or whatever age she was,
and these adults
and these students.
I think restorative justice
is a much better way
to approach school discipline
and punishment as opposed
to zero tolerance policies.
Because zero tolerance
policies disproportionately
affects children of color.
And it actually doesn't
lead to a better outcome.
Because even if you
just suspend a kid,
they don't truly understand
what they did wrong
and how to rectify
their mistake.
And I think that a
lot of these schools
really do a great job
with restorative justice.
And I think a democratic
meeting, obviously
is going to be harder on a scale
if you have thousands of kids.
But I mean, there
is a high school
I mentioned in the book,
Hanover High School,
that-- I'm not sure how
many students they have.
But they have students
elect representatives,
like they have a
student council.
Not like most
American high schools
where you have a student
government, which
is really based on
popularity and oftentimes
not very democratic.
And the school
administration kind of
doesn't really care
very much about them.
This school, there is a
very large student council
where they have
this big election
at the beginning of
the year and they
get to lobby the school board.
And they have teachers on there.
It's a really amazing
democratic process.
And the kids, they debate
all kinds of issues,
from homework
policy, to testing,
to installing water
fountain, things like that.
It's a really
interesting democratic--
in a democratic fashion.
So yeah, I'd love to see
that happen in more schools.
MANUSHI SHAH: But isn't the
number of issues that arise,
is getting higher.
So how do you handle those?
When you consider each issue
that 7-year-old to 20-year-old
is going to bring
up in [INAUDIBLE].
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
No, it's a good question.
So the example of Summerhill
School, for example.
They actually have something
called ombudsman and beddies
officers.
This is a boarding school.
So an ombudsman is essentially
a student who is elected.
The individual has been at the
school for at least two years.
They're usually
an older student.
And an ombudsman
basically is charged
with settling small
disputes between students.
And oftentimes, it's
between younger students.
Just fighting, or somebody
called each other a name,
like a small, little thing.
An ombudsman, who's
an older kid who
is charged with
settling that dispute,
with making sure that the
tedious, minor disputes don't
go into the school meeting.
And they have beddies officers.
So at this school,
it's a boarding school,
beddies officers wake
up and put kids to bed.
It's to make sure that they are
not running around at night.
And there is amazing--
I think because older kids
take on that responsibility,
the community
functions a lot better.
And not every case makes it to
the school meeting necessarily.
The chair, or the person who's
coordinating the meeting,
has to decide whether
this is reasonable
or we can decide this
in another fashion.
So I think there is kind
of structures in place
to ensure that it
doesn't get cobbled down
by a lot of unnecessary cases.
SUNNI YUEN: So let's talk tests.
It is the one thing I've left
behind for good, hopefully.
Maybe not.
But you actually distinguish
at length the difference
between a test
and an assessment.
In your book, you
say that a test
is used to tell whether
a student has memorized
and regurgitated [INAUDIBLE]
material, while an assessment
is an ongoing process for
evaluating, documenting,
and reflecting.
And so I am curious, because
it seems like your distinction
and your arguments here hinge
on two distinct aspects.
1, which is format of a test
and the purpose of a test.
And I think anybody here who
has had to deal with a number 2
pencil and a Scantron sheet can
probably say that at some point
they've taken a multiple choice
test which was only created
to test superficial knowledge.
And also, it was summative.
It was meant for the
purpose of determining
what the final grade was.
But is there any reason why
a test can't be actually
formative and a good gauge
of a student's development?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah, no.
Really good question.
Well, I distinguish
between the two just
for the purposes
of this argument.
And this is a term,
I think-- I mean,
I find that progressive schools,
they don't use the term "test"
necessarily.
They use the term "assessment."
And assessment is more so-- I
mean, performance-based tests
or portfolio-based assessment.
And that's what I think the
distinguishing factor is.
Like a traditional
standardized test and multiple
choice are based
on memorization.
But I think, yeah.
I think there is a lot
of debate and discussion
around this issue.
I mean, there are some-- I
mean, one of the things that's
kind of thing and I didn't
mention in this book
because it just happened.
President Obama just signed the
Every Student Succeeds Act back
in December.
And one of the things-- and
they use this language also,
I believe.
They say that schools can
move-- some states are allowed
to move away from traditional
standardized tests towards more
performance-based assessments.
So like, that's where I think
the language is more so used.
So they can use portfolios,
or performance-based tests,
or experiential
learning methods.
It's more so different than a
traditional standardized test.
So I just think that's
kind of the language
that people are
using these days.
SUNNI YUEN: So how do you
feel about spelling bees?
Do they need to go?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Well,
I mean, I have
nothing against spelling bees.
Yeah, I mean, feel free to
participate in a spelling bee.
SUNNI YUEN: But do you
think that they are only
meant to test regurgitation?
NIKHIL GOYAL: I mean, it depends
on the way you approach it.
Because I mean, a
lot of times it does.
There's a lot of evidence.
I mean, I've heard stories of
kids who do the spelling bee
and they use a very rea-llife
application base to it.
They find contractual
ways to learn those words
without necessarily just kind
of cramming the information.
I mean, like one of
the things I mention.
I mean, similar not
necessarily in spelling bees,
but the issue of
rote memorization.
And I think, like the evidence
around acquiring and retaining
information.
I mean, there's
a lot of evidence
around project-based
learning that
shows that project-based
learning actually
leads to long-term retention
because you're repeating
the task over and over again.
And you're solidifying
the information
with the real-life applications.
So it has a real meaning
to you as opposed to you
just kind of did
this at one time.
You studied for the
test and this is it.
I think I personally find that
the project-based learning
experiences that
I've had in school,
like the afterschool
programs, I can remember that
very vividly today, where
I can't very much remember
most of what I learned in
chemistry class in 10th grade.
So I'd love to see that
happen in more schools.
SUNNI YUEN: Now, there
are two testing consortia
that have arosen out of
the Common Core work, which
is the Partnership
for Assessment
Readiness for College and
Careers and Smarter Balanced.
And these are consortia which
are focused on developing tests
that assess critical thinking
and pathways to improvement
rather than just
rote memorization.
Do you think that they're
on the right track
to revolutionize
standardized testing in a way
that it could be formative
rather than simply summative?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Well, I
have not studied PARCC.
I believe it's PARCC
you're referring to?
I have not studied
that in-depth.
But what I've heard from parents
is that there is a lot-- and as
well as many educators,
there's a lot
of concern about the way PARCC
is implementing their tests.
Again, I have not studied
PARCC very in-depth,
but I've just heard many
concerns about that.
Under the Every
Student Succeeds Act,
there is, I think,
seven states that
are allowed to move away
from standardized tests,
like the traditional forms.
So I think that's
really good progress.
I'd love to see that
happen on a larger scale.
But the other issue
is accountability
in terms of what these
tests are used for.
I find it very concerning
when tests are used
to assess and fire teachers.
And also, along the
lines of grading schools.
Because when you find-- I
mean, a lot of these tests
are very much so based on
socioeconomic indicators.
I mean, there's a lot of studies
to show that teachers have
a very small portion
of the control over how
well a student does.
Kids in high-achieving
communities
generally do better
on standardized tests
for a number of reasons.
One is that the culture
of and the language used
on these tests is more
resembling a more white
middle-class environment.
Whereas, a poor kid is probably
not going to get as much
of success on these tests
for a number of reasons
because of their
socioeconomic background.
So I think standardized tests
have a strong correlation.
And the SAT is a
perfect example.
If you look at family income
as you go up the brackets,
the standardized
test scores go up
and the SAT scores go
up in an upward fashion.
So yeah, I think
there's a lot of-- I'm
hopeful to see the
changes that are happening
under Every Student
Succeeds, but I do worry
about the kind of
accountability structures
that may result from that.
Teachers have been very,
very angry about this.
I mean, they've protested in
numbers around the country
around, they call them
value-added evaluations,
where the teacher is
basically evaluated
based on the kid's test score.
And they can get fired for that.
SUNNI YUEN: But that's part
of your criticism of the Race
to the Top program, right?
Where I think in
your book you had
mentioned that the $4 billion
program passed as part
of the stimulus package.
You said you felt that because
of the size of the stimulus,
and at a time when it was
granted during the Great
Recession a few years ago, that
it was basically strong-arming
states--
NIKHIL GOYAL: Nobody
knew about it.
SUNNI YUEN: --to comply with
policies promoted by the Race
to the Top [INAUDIBLE].
But the thing is that out
of the initial tier that
was provided under the American
Recovery and Reinvestment Act,
of the $100 billion,
$50 billion of that
was actually dedicated and
earmarked to save teacher jobs.
So how do you address that?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
No.
So first thing.
Race to the Top, it was a piece
of legislation, a $4.35 billion
program started by
Arne Duncan, who
was the CEO of Chicago schools.
And the stimulus
package-- I mean,
this was a massive package.
As a person who was
involved in education,
as a person who follows
education news, and talking
to people who were very
active at that time,
did not know about
Race to the Top.
This was not a program
that was very well-known
in the education community.
And that's why there wasn't
this kind of opposition to it
from that forefront.
In terms of the firing
and hiring teachers.
Yeah, no.
I think there's a lot
of really good-- it did
save a lot of teachers' jobs.
But what I'm referring to is
the value-added evaluations,
which have-- basically, ,
under a Race to the Top,
a state had to abide
by certain principles.
So one of them was the
Common Core standards.
Another one was implementing
more charter schools.
SUNNI YUEN: Though, actually.
I think Race to the
Top program never
actually, by its terms, required
the adoption of the Common
Core.
NIKHIL GOYAL: It
doesn't say that.
SUNNI YUEN: It encouraged
states to develop
standards, which is not exactly
the same as Common Core.
NIKHIL GOYAL: It
did say Common Core.
I'm pretty sure it
said Common Core.
SUNNI YUEN: No.
NIKHIL GOYAL: But my point is
that they strong armed states
into pushing for
these-- Arne Duncan
was a proponent of
these standards.
He was a strong supporter of
these standards at the time.
But here's my point.
My point is, is that the
stimulus, obviously, did
a lot of really good things.
It saved a lot of jobs.
But in New York
state, for example,
they did pass-- they were one
of the states that did receive
the Race to the Top money.
And they did implement
value-added evaluations.
And it's caused a lot of
upheaval by educators.
It's massive dissatisfaction
with that system.
Like I said, there's
a lot of evidence
to show that standardized
test scores are very much
so tied to teacher evaluations.
I mean, on the issue of
firing and hiring teachers,
early in Obama's term in 2009,
I believe it was Central Falls.
It was a very poor
Rhode Island district.
They fired all their teachers
or most of their staff.
And Obama and Duncan
supported that measure.
I mean, they were
totally behind that
because they found that
this school district was
very low-performing.
And there was massive backlash
from the teachers union.
I read about that, Central
Falls in Rhode Island.
So yes, they did save jobs.
But a lot of educators have been
very critical of those changes.
SUNNI YUEN: So maybe it was
an implementation issue?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
I mean, my thing
is, if you're going
to talk about education
policy, you're
going to have to
include the stakeholders
in that conversation.
They did not have enough of an
effort to include the educators
and students.
People I know did not
know about Race to the Top
until it was passed.
It was not something
that was very well-known.
Maybe that's part of the media.
Maybe it was part
of the strategy.
But I don't think
it was developed
in a way that necessarily was as
cohesive as it could have been.
MANUSHI SHAH: So
just getting back
to the whole idea of letting
students learn by themselves,
you're assuming that
inherently they are just
going to be interested in
learning by themselves,
even at the age
of three or four,
which is when they're most
curious about things in life.
How do you intend
to force students
who are not interested?
Like by the age of
11 or 12, they just
don't want to learn anything.
If you give them a choice
of playing video games
and watching TV,
they might just defer
to that instead of learning
or doing any projects.
So would you force them?
NIKHIL GOYAL: It's a
very good question.
So here's what I'd say.
So first of all,
children-- I mean,
children are natural learners.
You go to any preschool.
I mean, children
are deeply engaged
in the practice of learning.
And play, I argue,
is a very strong form
of learning, at least
in the early ages.
I give the example of
the Brooklyn Free School,
like talking about video
games and television.
The Brooklyn Free School,
it's a private school
with sliding scale tuition.
I believe large
population of color.
They do offer a certain number
of families free tuition.
So they do have economic
diversity in that form.
And the school,
one of the things
I was wondering, like, yeah,
it's a really good question,
where if you just let a
kid, kind of sit around,
do whatever they want, are they
just going to play video games?
And what you find
is that the kids who
came from traditional schools,
they come to this school
and they see all this freedom.
Basically, they gravitate
towards the things that were
basically controlled before.
So they go to the video games.
They play video games.
They watch television.
They're on the computer.
They watch YouTube.
They're not doing anything
that's so-called "productive"
in your sense.
But what you find-- I give
this story of one student
named Louise.
And she did that for
maybe a couple of months.
She was just sitting
around and she
was very-- she was completely
isolated from everyone else.
And what happened
was that she realized
because of everyone else around
her was engaging in learning.
They were going on field trips.
They were doing
volunteer opportunities.
There were classes available.
Everyone else was engaged
in some kind of activity.
And she was just left alone.
It was just kind
of peer pressure
where she wanted to be part
of the school community.
And the students actually
call it a period of detox.
They literally
call it that term,
where you have to kind
on unlearn and relearn
what you're most interested in.
And that process can take
a very, very long time.
Because if you just
throw a kid into
an unstructured environment
from a structure environment,
it's going to take a very
long time for that transition
to happen.
So yeah, I think
the kids do learn.
And they go through that period
of detox, which is, I think,
very important.
I have not seen a
case of that school,
for example, that has--
they've just been left alone
and not done any classes.
But Summerhill is also
a very good example,
where I find the
kids, many kids,
don't take a single
formal lesson
until 12 or 13 years old.
For six, seven
years, they have not
taken a single formal lesson.
Yet, the kids have
learned how to read.
They've learned how to read
through computer games.
For example, "Minecraft."
Many kids learn reading
through "Minecraft."
They work through play.
Or an older kid helped them out
with the words and the letters
and they learned how to read.
Or, through other [INAUDIBLE].
Or they may have taken a
formal lesson at some point.
Yet, they've learned how to
read and do basic literacy
and numeracy by that point.
And then at that time, there
is this kind of realization
amongst the student
population that I
need to begin to, so-called
"formally prepare" a little bit
for college or adult life.
And they begin to take classes.
I mean, I have not seen
a case when I was there
for all the kids who were
in, like the 13 to 15
demographic, who
weren't taking classes
or who weren't preparing
for something called
the GCSE exams for college.
So yeah, I think if you
have a community where there
is enough and ample
opportunities for learning,
and there are these kinds
of structures in place
to encourage kids to take
on a more formal lesson.
I mean, kids are not completely
resistant to what adults think.
I mean, they're oftentimes
very intelligent human beings.
If you encourage them
and if you show them
that here are some really
good opportunities,
then they will take them.
So yeah, I would love to see
more research done on this.
A lot of this is,
unfortunately, very anecdotal.
But yeah, I would love to see
more research on this issue.
MANUSHI SHAH: But
in that case, it's
usually when you have
progressive school already
in place, where
there are a hundred
kids who are learning this way.
And then you put two
or three students
from traditional school who
will just follow this idea.
But you can't just change
the whole structure
and expect them to
be just-- undo that.
NIKHIL GOYAL: Right.
It's a good question.
It's a good point.
What I would say is that
I think the solution is
to start pilot programs within
existing schools themselves.
So a lot of these schools,
they have alternative education
programs.
In Great Neck on
Long Island, they
have the Village School, which
is an alternative school that's
been around for decades.
So you create these kinds
of progressive programs
within the existing school
buildings themselves,
and then you work
on expanding it.
Because I'd love
to see this-- you
try this out with, say, a
group of kids who are really
interested in doing this.
And then you expand it
to more and more kids.
Or, you try what the
consortium schools are like
and you work with that
kind of population
of students who have been
very disengaged by schools.
But I think a pilot program
is a much better option.
There's a school
in Massachusetts
that started something called
the Independent Project.
And this was a group of 10
high school students who
wanted to be able to
get away from the rules
and the requirements
that are required
of them in the
traditional school day.
And so they wanted to
work on their own project.
They decided, let's create our
own school within the school.
Let's have a couple of teachers
and mentors available to us.
And they did this.
And I think something like that
model, the Independent Project,
which has been around
for a couple years now,
can start in schools.
So yes, you're right
that if you just do this,
you're not going to necessarily
lead to the best results.
But if you start with
a group of students
and you slowly expand
that over time,
I think that can lead to
better outcomes in the future.
SUNNI YUEN: So what is this
magic, sort of age or epiphany,
when students who have gone
through a very unstructured
environment suddenly
decide, oh, I
want to study nuclear physics.
So I'm going to have to develop
a core set of competencies,
right?
Because if you
look at it, there's
the adult world, which I
think everybody in this room
falls into.
But you know, what about doctors
having to take the boards?
Do we get rid of
boards for doctors?
Do they need to be
qualified by taking an exam?
Should lawyers like me
have to take a bar exam?
Why?
What about accountants,
architects?
And even in education, I
think the dean of U Michigan's
education school had said
that there needs to be
a common set of standards.
And so the question is
sort of like, how do you
manage that
transition from going
from very individual,
project-based-driven learning
into sort of like where you've
got a very structured world?
Where the threshold to
even become an architect,
to become a
chartered accountant,
you have to take tests.
And they're going to
be standardized tests.
And they're going to be
hard and time-pressured.
And if you don't have that sort
of practice going through K
through 12 at some
point, you're just
not going to be that prepared.
Does that mean we should
invite the Kaplans of the world
to take over that role?
NIKHIL GOYAL: It's a
very good question.
So what I find is that the kids
in these progressive schools,
they actually have a very easy
time transitioning to college.
I mean, obviously
those are examples.
And I'm not in favor of
getting rid of these board
exams or requirements for--
SUNNI YUEN: Doctors.
NIKHIL GOYAL: For doctors.
I don't think that's even
part of this solution.
If I just may mention,
one of the things
that they are-- I was
reading at medical schools
is that they are trying to
move to more qualitative
measures of assessment.
Because they're
finding that they
want to show the
multi-dimensional facets
of an individual.
SUNNI YUEN: Yeah.
But that's a school versus--
NIKHIL GOYAL: I know.
SUNNI YUEN: [INAUDIBLE].
NIKHIL GOYAL: That's my point.
My point is I think they're
moving in that direction.
But my point is, is
that the students--
I find that they have
no difficulty taking
standardized tests.
At Summerhill, the kids take
many GCSE exams for college.
These are standardized exams.
And they find that
in college, even
if they're structured
environments,
the kids don't mind being there
because they chose to be there.
And they chose to
be in that class,
or they prefer that kind
of style of learning.
So I don't find that they
have any difficulty adapting
to that environment.
They actually say that the
kids who were kind of forced
into that, who never had the
practice of choosing what they
wanted to learn or taking more
responsibility in learning,
have difficulty going into
those college classes.
So yeah, I think there
is a lot of evidence that
shows that even kids
in progressive schools
can do the more structured
standardized learning.
And they do well in
college and later on.
I mean, you gave me the
example of doctors and lawyers.
And maybe those are
extreme examples.
They're like examples
of certain professions
where there is more
standardization required
of you.
But there's doctors and lawyers
that come out of these schools
as well.
So I think they can take
on those challenges.
SUNNI YUEN: But do you
think they're disadvantaged?
NIKHIL GOYAL: I don't think--
SUNNI YUEN:
[INAUDIBLE] pure fact
that they haven't had as much
practice at an earlier stage?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Well,
obviously if you're
driven in test prep
your entire life,
you're going to be
good at taking tests.
SUNNI YUEN: That's exactly it.
NIKHIL GOYAL: That's my point.
I think that that's not
the only thing in life.
I think that's not the
only thing that's-- yes,
you do need to take tests to get
into medical school and become
a doctor and such.
But there are
other things that I
think are also very important
qualities that we should
want to see in human beings.
SUNNI YUEN: So do you think
testing should be done only
at a final stage?
Anybody can go to med school.
Don't evaluate them
based on tests,
but wait till they
just take their boards.
Let the boards be
the final stage.
NIKHIL GOYAL: I have not studied
medical school, so I can't--
SUNNI YUEN: OK.
I'm just using it as an example.
NIKHIL GOYAL: Right.
No.
SUNNI YUEN: What is
a right [INAUDIBLE]?
NIKHIL GOYAL: I'm
looking at K-12.
So I mean, I think
there-- I have not
studied the practice
of law or medicine,
so I can't speak on that.
But in terms of the
K-12 system, yeah, I'm
all in favor of having--
these progressive schools,
the public progressive
schools in New York,
they have regular
performance-based tests,
checking out what the
kids are working on.
And if you're in a small school,
you don't even necessarily
need those tests.
If you have a
strong relationship
and the teacher
knows where you are,
the teacher can
individually determine where
you stand on a certain subject.
And they can mark where you are.
That's, obviously, a
very ideal situation.
But yeah, I mean,
there's nothing wrong
with having a few
assessments here and there
in these schools.
And they do so.
MANUSHI SHAH: So
just to conclude,
you're saying that K
through 12 public schools,
progressive schools and
democratic make sense.
But undergrad or
grad, or anything
after, you would
keep the way it is?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Well, I'm
not saying I'd necessarily
keep the way it is.
I have just not studied
the grad system as much.
But I find that a lot of
graduate schools, at least
in-- I mean, I haven't studied
the American system very much.
But the UK system, there
are very few tests.
A lot of it is very
based on submitting
essays, and research,
and the work you do.
At least in the humanities.
SUNNI YUEN: And oral exams.
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
NIKHIL GOYAL: And
oral exams, yeah.
At Oxford and Cambridge,
that's essentially what you do.
You have oral exams.
And I mean, Oxford and Cambridge
have the tutorial system
where you have a tutor.
You go to that tutor.
It's like one-on-one instruction
and a very individual-based
approach.
And yeah, I think an oral
exam is a much better way
to tell whether
you know something
as opposed to taking
a standardized test
or a traditional test.
I mean, I'd love to see more
oral exams to happen in school.
Yeah.
Again, that's maybe another
topic for the future.
But K-12, I think that's
what I'd like to see.
MANUSHI SHAH: OK.
We can also open the
floor for any Q&A.
AUDIENCE: Nikhil, thank you.
It was really an
amazing discussion.
I enjoyed it.
I had this question
to you talking
about the democratic
process in schools.
But who decides
whether students need
to go to this kind of school
or to another kind of process?
Is this the role of parents,
districts, federal government?
What do you think?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
Well, most democrat schools,
as I mentioned, are private.
So that's obviously a
parent's decision to do that.
But there are these
alternative schools.
The problem with the alternative
schools is that a lot of them
are oftentimes only
reserved for kids
who are in special
education or are
completely disengaged
or ready to drop out.
They're not necessarily
for the kids who
are just going by school getting
A's, B's, C. Just going by.
So that's often a
district or a teacher
recommends a student to
go into this program.
But yeah, a lot
of it is parents.
I think an individual
district can decide
to set up a progressive school.
So the Workshop
School, for example,
is a school that was founded
by Simon Hauger and a couple
other people in 2013.
And it was sanctioned
by a school
district of Philadelphia.
So I think school
districts can play
a role in helping to create
more of these types of schools.
AUDIENCE: You obviously
want to have it
on much, much grander
scale than it is now.
NIKHIL GOYAL: Well, starting
off, I'd love to see--
AUDIENCE: Who will drive this?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Well,
I think policymakers
can do a lot of good in that.
Like I mentioned, I
think pilot programs.
I think, why don't
we start a couple
of these programs in schools and
study them around the country?
Or at least send a
group of officials
from the Department of
Education or State Departments
of Education to the schools
and let's see the effectiveness
and look at this research
on a larger scale.
And I think starting
with a school,
in a school you could have a
group of students trying this
out and seeing whether it works,
and seeing how it functions.
I would really encourage
that to happen.
And schools can do
that themselves.
Policymakers can do that.
And then, individual
educators can
advocate for those changes
in their districts.
So it comes from different
places, not necessarily
just one person.
But certainly, if the secretary
of education wants to do this,
I would love to see that happen.
But it's very unlikely that
he would want to do that.
AUDIENCE: So in
your ideal world,
if your kind of idea of how
education should be K to 12
were to roll out, how would
you see that happening?
And what would it look like?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Well, I think
one of my favorite models
is the School
Without Walls model.
And I think that would be
a really interesting thing
to try out in a couple of
cities where you-- I mean,
there'd be partnerships
between local community
agencies, the government,
and school districts.
I think there'd be kind
of like a database system,
where people can
get matched based
on, like an apprenticeship
or internship they work on,
and matched with adults
in that community.
And then, I think
there could be areas
where you can have classes and
activities available for kids.
One of the examples I talk
about in the book is in Chicago,
they have the Cities of
Learning Initiative, where
the kids in a summer program,
they-- because a lot of kids
who don't have access
to summer camps
are oftentimes just
playing on the street.
They don't have any
real opportunities.
They called it the
Summer of Learning
where they had a database of
activities where kids could
earn digital badges based on the
activities that they worked on.
And that was a really good
way to get kids, poor kids,
in these activities and learn
skills and gain knowledge.
And so I'd like to
see that happen.
It's happening in Los
Angeles, Pittsburgh,
and a couple of other cities.
So I'd like to see
a kind of database
where kids can choose
the activities they're
most interested in.
And then you could,
obviously, streamline that
based on individual
schools and teachers.
But again, these are obviously
very, sometimes far-fetched
ideas.
I would start with
a pilot program
and see where it
goes from there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned in passing
AMC, medical schools
are moving towards a more
whole person-based evaluation
of students as opposed to
just strictly objective,
do you pass these requirements?
That's all well and good.
The problem is--
well, one concern
is that raises the cost
of evaluating students.
And that would be particularly
important from the high school
to college level and college
to post-secondary level.
And one of the impacts would
be to potentially reduce
the number of students
who can access education.
Because oftentimes,
application fees
are not refundable
and not really covered
under any sort of financial aid.
Do you have any ideas on
how to address that problem?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
I mean, in terms of the cost.
I think, obviously, I'm in big
favor of free higher education.
And I think that would
include applying to college,
that there should
be at least waivers
or a place where kids
can-- for application fees.
Because it can be quite
exorbitant after some time.
Porfolio-based assessment,
at least-- there's
about 850 colleges in this
country that no longer require
the SAT or ACT for admissions.
These are schools
like NYU, Wake Forest,
a lot of liberal arts colleges.
Bennington, Hampshire,
and others, they
don't require the SAT or ACT.
Some of these, they
ask for students
to submit a portfolio of a
product they did, or a paper.
Bard, I think, announced a
couple years ago that students
could submit four 2,500-word
essays graded by a teacher.
I think those are kind of
interesting models to look at.
But yeah, cost is a big,
big factor for how--
because it will take more time
to evaluate those applications.
I mean, I was hearing
kind of one proposal
where a school could kind
of-- say a school doesn't want
to move towards that system.
You could have a situation where
a school could say to a kid,
say you have a lower
than 2,000 SAT score.
Then you could submit an
extra portfolio or something
that shows that you're
capable of certain tasks.
So that could be
a way for students
to show that they're
able to do things
beyond a standardized test.
And it might be a little
bit more cost effective
than asking every kid
to submit a portfolio.
So I think there's kind of
innovative approaches to that.
And I think a lot of
liberal arts colleges
are moving in that
direction, even if they
haven't done so already.
AUDIENCE: Nevertheless, there's
still a lot of back-end costs.
My last job was actually
admissions processing.
And it's still archaic.
Transcripts are
physically mailed around.
Would you propose any
incentives to perhaps streamline
or modernize that system?
NIKHIL GOYAL: Yeah.
I'm forgetting the
name, but there
is a consortium of
schools, of colleges,
that was recently announced
that was talking about this.
They were trying to create
a much more portfolio-based
approach.
I think it was a couple Ivy
League schools, Stanford,
that were saying that we
need to make it easier
for kids to apply to college.
And I think it included digital
transcripts, or at least
making that process streamlined.
I'm forgetting the name, but
there was something about that
recently.
AUDIENCE: I didn't hear anything
about it at my last job.
All right.
Yeah, it's just a
concern of mine.
It's something I've been kicking
around at the back of my head
because it is a real cost.
And I've only seen
applications become more
onerous on students, not less.
I think that's more of a
comment than a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for your talk.
It was interesting.
I had a question about as you
move to this system being more
widespread, if you can get
it past the pilot stage,
you would probably
have to train teachers
in how to teach in
this new system.
How do you propose to do
that on a large scale?
NIKHIL GOYAL: I
think that's actually
probably the second biggest
challenge, really transforming
graduate education schools.
And I don't think I have an
answer to that because it
is a monumental task.
Even if you have the
pilot program in place,
and you have teachers
who are trained
in a way that is
very traditional,
it's going to falter.
So I mean, I'd like to
see graduate education
schools change, but I
have not seen any movement
on that regard in
higher education.
But yeah, it's a
very good point.
It's something that I think
we need to talk about more.
SUNNI YUEN: Great.
Well, thanks so much, Nikhil.
Everybody, please check out
his book, "Schools on Trial,"
with a very catchy byline
on how freedom-- or rather,
"How Freedom and Creativity
Can Fix Our Educational
Malpractice."
NIKHIL GOYAL: Thanks
again for having me.
SUNNI YUEN: [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]